Encuentra la distancia entre el punto -2,
-4 este punto de aquí,
y la línea "y" igual a -1/3 de "x" más 2,
que es esta línea de aquí.
Ahora, para hacerlo solo tenemos que encontrar
la línea perpendicular a esta línea azul,
a "y" es igual a -1/3 de "x" más 2, que contenga
este punto de aquí...
que contenga este punto...
Entonces tenemos que obtener... tenemos que
obtener la ecuación de esta línea
y luego debemos de encontrar donde se intersecan
estas dos líneas.
Y luego tenemos que encontrar la distancia
entre estos dos puntos de intersección.
Y entonces tenemos la distancia más corta
entre este punto y esta línea de aquí.
El primer paso es determinar cual es la pendiente
de esta línea perpendicular.
La pendiente de la línea perpendicular va a ser,
el inverso negativo de la pendiente de esta línea azul.
Por lo que el inverso negativo de 1/3 negativo,
va a ser 3 positivo.
Entonces esta línea de aquí va a tener una
pendiente de 3.
Va a tener la forma de "y" igual a "3x" más
"b", donde "b" es la ordenada al origen.
Y a simple vista, se puede ver aquí, que
estará muy cerca de 2 pero verifiquemos eso.
Para saber el valor de "b",
sustituyamos este punto de aquí.
Sabemos, no solo que la pendiente de esta recta es 3,
sino también que este punto debe de pertenecer a ella,
por lo que este punto
debe de satisfacer esta ecuación.
Entonces cuando "x" es -2 y "y" es -4... entonces
tenemos... -4 es igual... a 3... por -2...
más "b"... déjame escribir el -2 ahí adentro...
3 por 2 negativo más "b".
Y ahora podemos resolver para "b".
Tenemos que -4 es igual a -6 más "b".
Y si sumamos 6 de los dos lados tenemos que,
2 es igual a "b" o "b" es igual a 2.
Entonces vamos a escribir que la ordenada
al origen para segunda línea es en 2.
Inmediatamente podemos ver o podemos verificar,
donde se intersecan,
ambas se intersecan al eje "y" en "y" igual a 2, para las dos, cuando "x" es igual a 0, "y" es igual a 2.
Si no fuera tan obvio podríamos igualar estas
dos ecuaciones, podríamos decir,
miren, tenemos "3x" más 2,
ahora sabemos que es "3x" más 2 porque "b" es 2.
Y cuando esta "3x" más 2
es igual a -1/3 de "x" más 2.
Bueno, veamos, si restamos 2 en ambos lados,
¿cuándo "3x" es igual a -1/3 de "x"?
Hay un par de cosas que podríamos hacer en
este momento.
Podríamos sumar 1/3 de "x" en ambos lados
y luego tendríamos 3...
tendríamos 3 más 1/3 que es lo mismo que 10/3 de "x"
igual a 0 y si multiplicas ambos lados por 3/10...
3/10 obtienes... obtienes "x" es igual a 0.
Entonces ambas líneas se intersecan cuando
"x" es igual a 0, para las 2,
cuando "x" es igual a 0, "y" es igual a 2... cuando "x"
es igual a 0, "y" es igual a 2,
pero lo pudiste haber visto aquí a simple vista.
Podrías haber visto que las
ordenas al origen de las 2,
que si "x" es igual a 0 y "y" es igual a 2, este punto es 0, 2 y ya sabíamos que este punto de aquí era -2, -4.
Y ahora, solo necesitamos encontrar la distancia
entre estos 2 puntos.
Y la fórmula de la distancia, es en realidad
solo una aplicación del teorema de Pitágoras.
Solo necesitas encontrar la distancia, el
cambio de la dirección en "y"
y el cambio en la dirección en "x".
Así que hagamos eso por separado.
Entonces en la dirección "y"... en la dirección
"y" que es esta distancia de aquí...
Fuimos desde "y" igual a -4, hasta "y" igual
a 2, esta distancia de aquí es 6 y
¿cuál es esta distancia de aquí?
Vamos de "x" igual a -2 a "x" igual a 0, por
lo que esta distancia de aquí es 2,
por lo que la distancia entre estos dos puntos, es
solo la hipotenusa de un triángulo recto
cuyos catetos son 6 y 2.
Así que podemos decir, si le llamamos
a esta distancia "d",
podríamos decir que la distancia
al cuadrado es igual a...
y lo único que estoy haciendo aquí es reafirmando la fórmula de la distancia.
La fórmula de la distancia te dice todo esto,
ya sabes, "y2"...
era "y2" menos "y1" que es 6 al cuadrado...
pero eso es solo el teorema de Pitágoras...
solo digamos 6 al cuadrado... 6 al cuadrado
más "x2" menos "x1" que es 0 menos 2 negativo,
lo que es 2 positivo al cuadrado,
va a ser igual a la distancia al cuadrado,
pero vemos que es solo el teorema de Pitágoras, de todas maneras resolvamos para la distancia.
Así que, la distancia al cuadrado, va a ser
igual a 36 más 4, que es 40 y ahora veamos.
40 es la distancia al cuadrado,
puedo solo decir que la distancia
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 40.
La raíz cuadrada de 40 es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de 4 por 10.
Entonces la distancia es igual a 2 si factorizamos
el 4, la raíz cuadrada de 4 por la raíz
cuadrada de 10, 2 es la raíz de cuatro, 2
por la raíz cuadrada de 10 y hemos terminado.